um
good morning and welcome to this
joint standards committee meeting on
thursday the 3rd of september
particularly welcome to those who are
the public who are on the
live streaming my name is simon quelch
i'm actually i'm an employee of the
council i'm the
what's called the monitoring officer and
i also am a lawyer
and the only reason that i'm chairing
this uh initial part of the meeting
is that there is no chairman or vice
chairman appointed
and that is what we are going to do now
um so in a moment i will call
four nominations for the chairman of
this
committee and that will that will remain
until the annual
statutory meeting when obviously that
matter will be considered again
uh members before we continue can you
please before your videos
and microphones are turned off um
and after we've done that i will ask
tara to to carry out a roll call because
i know there may be some substitutes in
this meeting so we can confirm which
members
are in attendance but before we do that
can i just mention to all members
that this committee meeting is scheduled
for approximately
two hours so
it's scheduled to last until around
about 11 30. obviously there's some
leeway
if matters take a little bit longer than
we think
but there is another committee meeting
later on
and committee services also have to
prepare
for that um and it requires quite a bit
of time in advance so if just members
could bear that in mind
as well so tara could you could you
kindly carry out the roll call
well yes of course members if you could
just indicate um
uh that you're present please when i
call your name and councillor bassinger
believe he's still trying to get in at
the moment good morning tara i'm here
thank you councillor helm
present thank you uh counselor hull
uh present thank you i'm here council
amaze
councillor maze
i think we might have lost councilman i
know she's with us we just can't just
come here
um councillor morley president
thank you councillor nunn
yes i'm here tara thank you very
[Music]
hello good morning i'm present good
morning and mr hodgson the independent
person
mr hodgson are you there yes i can see
i'm here thank you very much um
and could i just ask um any other
members in attendance to introduce
themselves just so we've got a record
please
good morning it's chrissy morris in the
house
council maurice that's the morning tara
cancer wendy stamps here as well
much
[Music]
fiddle
i i think that's everyone mr coach thank
you
councillor as well oh yes sorry thank
you
i mean is there any other council there
that's not a part of the committee but
that's actually in attendance
now's your chance to uh mention that
you're in
okay i don't i think that's it tomorrow
yeah thank you simon
okay
well he hasn't he hasn't um he hasn't
said he is so i assume he isn't
so he's not even got the enough respect
to at his android stuff
let's let's you're not a part of the
committee so can we just leave that i've
got to go
counselor morris i've got to now go on
to uh the nominations for a chairman
okay so so could you turn off your i'd
be grateful if you turned off your video
feed and your microphone so
we can do that as you've asked me so
nicely i shall comply
thank you very much
uh can i now ask any member
wishing to nominate to the position of
chairman
uh to unmute your microphone turn on
your video feed
and state your name and nomination
please
the passenger seconds it okay so we have
online issues
any other nominations
any other nominations just one
nomination for councillor helm
in the absence of any other nominations
then
counselor do all members are sent to
that do we have an ascent
do we have a general assent to that yes
in which case as i have generally sent
to that councillor helm
you are chairman of the joint standards
committee
for the rest of the municipal year and i
now pass over
uh to you for the rest of the meeting
which
which will require next the election of
a vice chairman
thank you very much simon and thank you
very much everybody um i now ask for
nominations from
for vice chairman from the chair i'd
like to nominate councillor nun
is that seconded yeah that's the second
dude
thank you very much
counseling did you say something yes
sorry nobody asked whether i would be
prepared to stand this vice chair
okay would you be prepared to stand then
no
no okay then have we got any other
nominations then please
can i um nominate councillor stamp
the committee and i'm only substituting
for her
but she's not here at the moment we have
to nominate people that are here at the
moment
she is here uh mr chairman
com oh she isn't here mr chairman
am i
can you repeat what you said am i
sorry sorry mr chairman um councillor
stamper is
here at this meeting not as a
member of the uh committee i believe is
that correct
that's correct but can i actually speak
because what you're what you've actually
done
new chairman um the previous chairman
councillor bob boyce did and
put maddie thompson in when she wasn't
present at the last meeting so i do
air a bit of caution here with the
decision you're about to make
simon quelch might be able to help you
simon can you please help me because i'm
trying to nominate someone who's from
here and obviously people don't agree
with that
well i i don't think there's anything to
prevent
so long as the person is a standing
member of the committee which um i
believe mrs
councillor stamp is then there's nothing
to prevent someone nominating
councillor stamp in her absence even
though she's not a part of the committee
today
thank you very much for clearing that up
simon apologies to councillor stamp
uh cat someone has nominated councillor
stamp have we got a second to please
second detention secondhead council
passenger
thank you all right we move on now the
children
mr chairman yes mr peter still speaking
um would it be best if when uh
councillor stamp
is present she wishes to agree to it
you know it's about some braces okay can
counsellor
stamp agree to that then
i mean when she is president she then
agrees to do it
okay then so we can move on now okay
yeah thanks
quite happy with that right okay um i
welcome everyone and then the following
agenda requirements before moving on to
procedure
two below the investigates for a
momentous officer if the investigator is
absent
invited to summarize the conclusion of
the report and to make any clarifying
remarks
and can i just interrupt with yes
sorry and there's just a few bits on the
chairs notices that need to be gone
through
and then we've got apologies for
bit then absence i've reading out the
script and uh
i'm totally unprepared for this as you
you realize
because it's been thrust on me and uh
i'm trying to find the chairman's
notices here
now
so
i've got no script for that tara so i
shall uh
challenge me to send it through an email
again quickly
uh i'll be in a muddle because i've got
to switch this off to go on to that and
come back on again
so um uh normally we do apologies for
absence don't we
yes chairman any apologies for absence
we've
um yes chairman um would you would it be
helpful if i just perhaps refer to a few
bits on the notices that were there
yes please um so the uh the first one is
just to remind members
um that ensure microphones remain muted
and the video feeds off when you're not
addressing the committee
and the meetings being hosted remotely
streaming live and recorded
and by being present you're giving your
consent to being recorded
and members and officers during each
item please use the chat function
uh to indicate if you wish to speak the
chairman will then invite you at the
appropriate time
and members are reminded that apart from
indicating you wish to speak or that you
have to leave the meeting the chat
function should not be used for any
other purpose
and please do not use the raised hand
function as this is
on if this is unavailable on all devices
and when speaking and referring to
agenda papers if possible please can you
ensure you reference a page number or
paragraph number
and members are asked if they need to
leave the meeting at any point that they
make it known
and use the check function to signify
that they need to leave the meeting
and then chairman and officers are asked
to introduce themselves
um if that would be helpful for you
thank you could officers introduce
themselves please
yes i i'm obviously here as an officer
but i've already introduced myself simon
quelch i'm the monitoring officer
thank you and uh the um investigator
thank you councillor helm my name is
alex allrum i'm a director of chai
associates and i'm the independent
investigator who was instructed to carry
out um the investigation into council of
civil's common complaint
okay thank you very much is anyone else
present
uh i believe that is everybody chairman
okay so um if you're happy can i move on
to apologies for absence
yes thank you very much for doing that
because i don't appear to have any
script to my paperwork here at all
general paperwork i've got i was totally
unprepared for this
thank you tara that's okay and so
chairman apologies have been received
from
uh council mrs channel council jarvis
council stamp council mrs thompson
um and in accordance with notice given
councillor hull is attending as a
substitute for council mrs channel
councillor swain as a substitute for
councillor um
stamp and councillor morley as a
substitute for councillor mrs thompson
thank you thank you very much
do i now go on procedure for complaints
determination
uh no chairman sorry next life my agenda
is minutes of the last meeting
uh minutes of the last meeting please
pages
five to ten chairman five to ten
do you agree this is a true and accurate
record
can i propose the please
afraid okay
jump in and say that i was actually in
attendance though it isn't recorded i am
mentioning the
body but i i was in attendance at that
meeting
and i the independent person is a member
of the committee
okay tara can you um
amend that minister to say that please
yes of course gentlemen we can make that
amendment no problem at all
okay now
where do we go from here tara sorry to
be a nuisance disclosure of interest
chairman
disclosure of interest please anyone got
any interest they wish to disclose
and nobody has indicated chairman and if
you have an interest during the meeting
will you please disclose it as soon as
possible
thank you
all right what's that sorry so chairman
the next item
um is agenda item seven
uh which is the standards complaint um
in relation to council agent fluker
and it's found on pages 11 to 54 of the
pack
and and the first item is is for mr
quelch to present that
report thank you mr quelch please
uh thank you chairman yes um
i really don't have anything to say
other than that i was the person that
instructed
mr auram as the independent investigator
and obviously from there on he took
charge of the matter in terms
of interviewing assessing the evidence
and then writing the report that you
have in your pack
um his conclusion is clear
and really i now pass over to to mr
auram so that
if so that if maybe he would like just
to comment on his report and confirm the
conclusion that he's reached chairman
with that if yeah that's fine if you
could do that please uh
carry on um just to interrupt council
none has a question
mr none thank you
thank you very much mr chairman uh mr
quelch
um just before we move on to the report
uh looking at your covering two pages
that's page 11 and page 12.
um i've asked this sort of question
before but i'd like some clarification
for
all present please of the list of
sanctions that you've listed here
can you just clarify how many of those
this committee is actually empowered to
uh
impose as opposed to recommend
and would be subject to full council
right okay now um if we go
to obviously number one on my report at
page 12 in paragraph
3.3 i think that's what you're referring
to counselor nun
number one obviously in a sense is
already
it's going to happen naturally because
committee minutes go
to council for noting um
number two now there's two aspects to
this i've only put in the formal one
jsc itself can impose essentia
according to the constitution
but that wouldn't be what's called a
formal censure it has in the past
issued its own censures and that is
within the constitution
i haven't put that in there i'm glad
you've asked the question because within
two
is the power for jsc to issue essentia
now by recommending to council
that is a sense is a level up because it
then would require the vote of
all members in council itself
to issue a formal censure and rather
than that being signed by the chairman
of the standards committee as we have in
the past
done um quite uh as a sort of informal
resolution
this would then be signed by the
chairman of the council so within
within number two there is a power for
jsc to issue its own censure
there is a greater power to recommend
one to cancel
okay sorry
number three instructing the monitoring
officer to arrange training for the
member
uh that is a power vested in jsc
number four again recommend to council
again that's the wording of the
constitution
and um again
that goes to full council if you want to
withdraw facilities
and i i've given an example there it
could also
include non-use of the office other than
for me
formal council meetings that will be a
recommendation to council
and then five obviously uh removal from
an official position
from committee or from any working group
again requires council a council
decision
oh that's the majority of the foreign
yeah uh yeah and that would be my by
majority vote yes
thank you that's my first time so the
only thing not covered in my report
is the power to censure which does exist
for jsc
thank you that's my first question my
second question relates to
item 5 on page 12 which is the
list of implications i was surprised
that it reads none bearing in mind the
content of the report
which we've all read i'm sure because
um in the report of 1.3 and 5.26
it does seem to indicate that there are
implications for our customers
and in the report at 1.2 it does seem to
indicate that there are implications in
terms of the qualities
well chairman um
it wouldn't be for me for me to put in a
report
on an undetermined
adjudication what are the implications
because you may decide there is no
bridge
i i am therefore presupposing if i put
something in on that particular
point about implications for customers
uh that there has been a breach so i can
see
i hope you can see my position there in
writing the report
the second point on resources is
this is the implications for the council
following on
from um the report which yes
obviously there was a fee for mr orem of
course there was
um but this is now following on
from that so what are the implications
of
the recommendation that i put in my
report
those three recommendations that that's
what
we're dealing with well i'm happy to
move on but i would have thought mr
quote that you would have listed
potential implications uh under
the investigator was going to go through
his report i believe
hello
hi thank you councillor helen
um it's not uh it's not my intention to
uh
to read you through the report i'm i'm
making an assumption that all members
have had the opportunity to uh look
through
the content um and take everything
forward
i'm happy to answer any questions that
members may have but
um i i will just briefly summarize um
my conclusions if that's agreeable
all right obviously we were instructed
to investigate a complaint that was made
uh by councillor siddal and which
members will find on page 43
of their agenda bundle
thanks this little complaint related to
um
alleged conduct by councillor fluka over
a significant period of time in fact a
period of time exceeding councillor
siddal's own
um time as a counsellor and he set out a
chronology
um in his complaint of various
occasions where he has been concerned
about the way he's been treated by
councillor fluker
now the um obviously the investigation
to try to uh focus on establishing
um the facts in relation to those
incidents
um given councillor for lucas uh
decision not to engage with the
investigation
uh it was difficult to know which if any
of the alleged uh incidents
were in dispute which is normally the
starting point of any investigation
um we decided
um though despite not having any
um obviously any contrary view to the
complaint
we decided to interview a number of uh
councillors
uh about the alleged incidence
councillors that were informed
witnessed some of the alleged conduct
and uh
they're listed on page 21 of the agenda
bundle
um under the subheading the
investigation
now
obviously the next section of the report
deals with
um our investigation and the findings of
that investigation
um i'm gonna assume as i said that
members had an opportunity to
to read through that and i won't dwell
on that at all
obviously once um the investigation has
established
the facts as satisfied um
by those we interviewed uh we had to
make some considerations about whether
the code of conduct had been
breached now the first point of call on
that is deciding whether
actually the alleged conduct comes
within the jurisdiction
of the localism act members will be
aware that
um councillors are not um
obliged to comply with the code of
conduct at all times
they're only obliged to comply with the
code the code can only be applied to
their conduct
when they're conducting cancelled
business
i have given some more general thoughts
on that in
annex b of the report
but page 35 and 36
feels specifically with my thoughts in
relation to
counselor fluker's conduct and members
will see that
whilst i'm satisfied that council of
lucas conduct
when um he attended council meetings and
when he engaged with council officers
does fall within the jurisdiction of the
code i i did not believe that his uh
conduct at conservative group meetings
and prior to that um during the
selection process that council said or
went through to become a councillor
i did not believe that they did fall
within the jurisdiction members of
course are welcome to take their own
view
my reasoning hopefully is clearly set
out in the report and i'm happy to take
questions
turning then to the conduct that um
did occur the code deals with fairly
nebulous terms like
treating others with respect um without
necessarily defining it
and i felt it was important for me to
define
what i felt is meant by those
paragraphs of the code before deciding
whether the conduct
um breached those aspects and so members
will see
on page 37
and 38 of the agenda pack
that i've set out my own thoughts on
the code principles and and given some
further detail
and being a little bit more prescriptive
on what i believe they
represent now i'm aware that all local
authorities have their own
culture and again it's in in part the
standards committee's
role and responsibility to decide what
culture they want
within their own organization but just
to be clear to members
my own thoughts and my own reasoning as
to whether the code has been breached
is is predicated on the principles that
i've set out on
those pages in paragraphs 5.10 5.11
and 5.12 and again i'm happy to take
questions
many members about that
moving on then to applying counsellors
fluker's conduct to those principles
i've set out in from paragraph 35.13
onwards
um my thoughts about
cancer flucus conduct and i've
highlighted at paragraph
5.17
where i believe counselor fluker's
conduct
did represent failure to comply with the
code
i understand that some of these
incidents have been discussed by the
stands committee
before in relation to other complaints
that were raised
and whilst i haven't looked in any
detail at the investigation that was
carried out
in that regard councillor fluka's
comments
to members at that committee meeting did
give me an opportunity to consider
his point of view and i've gone on in
the report to
set out why i think despite councillor
fluka's
descriptions of his own conduct or his
own intentions
why they still amount to a failure to
comply with the code
and i hope that has been clearly set out
in a way that members
can understand but again i'm happy to
take any questions
thank you sorry members any questions
please
please
to speak thank you very much councillor
nunn then councillor swine and then
councillor whatever it was i can't
remember
thank you um yes thank you mr lawrence
for your excellent report and for your
presentation
uh probably a bit of an unfair point to
start off with mr
aurora but i'll ask it nevertheless um
your report didn't cost 50
000 pounds did it no it did not
thank you very much uh it's been widely
reported that this
uh investigation
so thank you for clarifying that i mean
i i have i haven't yet
um sent an invoice um to
the authority that obviously our the
time will be
concluded once this this hearing has
finished um
but i i can i can assure members that um
it won't
get um anywhere near um even
five figures that's very kind of you to
clarify that thank you very much
turn into your report then can we go to
paragraph
4.3 please that's on
page
in the um third paragraph we also
interviewed another member of the
council
are you with me yes thank you um
is anonymity appropriate
in such an investigation bearing in mind
that we are
publicly elected representatives and in
the spirit of
openness as elected representatives is
anonymity
acceptable anonymity can be acceptable
counsellor
um depending on um no i mean the
localism act doesn't compel
or can't compel anybody to give evidence
including the member under investigation
um
it is hoped that councillors
who are signed up to the code will
um do all that you can to ensure
that this application um is
as transparent and open as possible
but there are many occasions where there
might be sensitivities involved or
concerns where
where um those involved in the
investigation
uh don't wish their identity to be known
now
my preference is not to rely on evidence
provided by those
who do not wish to have their um
identity known we were
obviously we approached a number of
councillors about being involved in this
and uh we interviewed a number and it
was decided
having obtained the evidence from the
various councillors that
in fact there would be no need to rely
on any of the evidence
provided by the witness who wanted to
remain anonymous
and therefore we haven't included any of
their evidence or relied on it in the
report
okay thank you very much for clearing
that up so in the same paragraph
explorer 4.3 uh
the last paragraph on page 21. um
is it usual in your experience
for a counselor in an investigation
it's not usual no um i've conducted
probably well in excess of 300 standards
investigations
and i would say that a member
who is under investigation not
cooperating
we're looking at probably 10 or 11 cases
over that period and
have those other cases involved a leader
off the top of my head um possibly one
but but i'm not certain
and uh is the failure to cooperate in
itself
bridge code of conduct
well i mean that would be for that would
be for members to decide themselves
um it's um in in a sense
uh members may feel they're limited to
only being able to breach
the council on conduct that's been
alleged and referred for investigation
however i have given my own thoughts um
if you'll just bear with me for a second
during my considerations as to whether
councillor
fluka has brought his office or
authority into disrepute
which can be found on page 41
of the agenda
and you will see um in the second half
of paragraph 5.27
i've i've acknowledged that while it's
counsellor through fluka's prerogative
not to involve himself that i have been
disappointed by it
and pointed out that the current
standards framework does rely on the
cooperation of councillors and their
commitment to upholding the code
and its associated procedures and that
one would might
expect the leader in particular to try
and set an example in that regard
thank you mr aurora sorry to quizzing
you but nearly there
just uh two left to go uh 4.4.2
uh but turning to the section on page 30
in italics part of your investigation
there
there's a reference towards the end of
the first paragraph on page 13.
yes well that was that was that was
evidence
well that was evidence given to us by
councillor jarvis
so that isn't that isn't a finding of
our investigation or a conclusion that
has been made
that was an account given to us by
councillor jarvis
now council of luca allegedly lying to
the monitoring officer
it was not something that was referred
to us for investigation
and so we did no further investigation
into that
or made any conclusions or findings of
fact
on it it is simply included as part of
councillor
jarvis's evidence in relation to the
matter that we were
investigating which
for that particular paragraph i believe
refers to the throat slitting gesture
okay thank you and my thank you very
much mr laura
and my final question uh at this stage
is on page 31 at 4.4.5
now i hope you can help me with this
because i'm struggling
this issue about um saying hello which
in itself is a
rather dated uh isn't it but
anyway hello sabre um is being
uh interpreted in two ways first of all
it's being
interpreted
uh in terms of sexuality
uh and secondly it's been interpreted as
a friendly uh greeting because of
yachting uh because of their mutual
interest
now what i'm struggling with here is the
inclusion
that had in the report 4.4.5
that
in order to wind him up yes
why would um a mutual interest
in yachting uh actually um
equate to winding somebody up by calling
them hello
by saying hello
do you you're saying what sorry sorry
counseling
you're saying do i believe he was trying
to wind
danceless i'm trying to work out
with those two interpretations if
if for example we followed the logic
that
it was a greeting between two dots
why would cope cancel durham you might
not be able to
answer durham but why would councillor
durham be saying
it was said in order to wind him up if
it was a mutual
um greeting by sailors
yeah i mean as as you say that might be
a better question put to council at
durham
my own thoughts were that um it wasn't
intended as a normal greeting between
two um yachtsmen um
but that it was um a deliberate um
attempt to mock
councillor siddal my i mean i would i
would i would point you to
paragraph 5.22 and 5.23 of my report
which are on page 40 of the bundle
yeah there you will see that um
based on the evidence that we received
in particular
relating to councillor fluka's tone the
tone in manner in which he made the
comment
um we felt that um
the evidence suggested that he had
adopted a camp manner
and and therefore that um the comment
was more likely to be
um made in a sort of mocking
manner and in 5.23
a lot of the members we spoke to did
suggest that um they thought it probably
had been
done in that way but that it hadn't been
vindictive
it had been effectively a joke or banter
um and we've said out in in that
paragraph
um why we think that that even if that
were the case and obviously we didn't
get an opportunity to ask councillors
luca
but even if that were the case we would
still consider it a breach of the code
of conduct
okay thank you very much mr warren i'm
sorry to have taken up so much
time very helpful thank you
that's all right councillor now next one
please tara
and chairman that was councillor maize
who i'll speak next thank you
uh yeah thank you mr chairman for this
opportunity
um i'd like to thank uh mr orrimund ch
and i associates for a very thorough
report
the same as councillor nunn um you've
just been um
speaking about um the paragraph
uh about the hello sailor which was on
page
51. sorry page 40.
um i am intrigued as to why
that this has not been engaged with at
all
in your recommendations um
as this is um uh
i don't know much about referring to my
notes um
that you've not referred to it at all in
relation to
uh council frugal's actions in his
capacity
um and and the evidence is very strongly
homophobic
why has this not been included as a
recommendation as a breach
i'm i'm sorry if it wasn't clear um
it has been included we've we've
concluded that
um that council flukes both failed to
show
treat councillors with respect and that
he bullied him
and um 5.17
sets out this specific occasion from
which
we believe this is evident and
the third bullet point of that state
refers to the fact that councillor
cibral
tiddle when talking to councillors
italian are deliberately affected in
camp manor at the september council
meeting
um both in relation to his attire and
with the comment hello sailor
uh yes thank you mr auram however in our
general obligations under our rules of
conduct
um 3.5 a
um is you must not do anything that may
cause the authority to breach any
of the equality enactments um is not
um breach of the equality act 2010
for the homophobic remarks that were
made within the chamber
um not not applicable in this particular
case
um no not quite sure why that has not
been applied
it wouldn't and i'm i'm happy to send
more information about that outside
of the meeting i have uh you know
uh reasoning with regards what would be
required for a member to
lead the authority to breach its
equality obligations
um that wasn't part of my considerations
and so i haven't included in the report
apologies for that
but this that that section of the code
um would more likely relate to decisions
that are being made that would then lead
to actions by the authority
that would be breach of the equalities
act
rather than the individual comments or
conduct of a counsellor
outside of decision making does that
does that make sense
even though this is a protected
character characteristic
even though it's a protected
characteristic yes it's it's more about
um it's it's more about uh you know the
way the authority treats its
uh its constituents as it were and
council's decisions in relation to that
the application of policies and
procedures
so you've actually dealt with this under
the
the bullying element i have yes
yes i didn't i didn't think it engaged
the
the equalities legislation again i can i
mean if
i can go into more more detail on that
if you give me a couple of minutes
or i can provide it with you would you
like me to do that
that would be helpful thank you very
much okay give me one second
i'm just going to get off my colleague
one second okay okay
chairman i don't know if it would be
helpful but councilman got a question
for camp for mr quelch
i don't know
yes yes thank you chairman um mr i
i just wondered um really why
more councillors or sorry why their
views weren't taken really with um
if they were anonymous it was all is
that really
a thing that's really done in procedures
like that and
and also um
it says here in 4.39
page 28 uh how was it
really um decided if it was intended
to be expensive or not really i can't
understand
it either it's a faithful voice isn't it
thank you sorry chairman did you want me
to answer that
yes please yes um i think mr auram has
already sort of answered that
uh question in relation to anonymity um
there's nothing in the localism act that
requires people to actually cooperate
and therefore that means that sometimes
a a counsellor may say um
i want to witness that is not the
subject member
um because obviously all counsellors
whether they're the subject member
or a witness should cooperate really
with any investigation
but if they have a particular reason for
wanting to give evidence but to do so
anonymously
then that can be done it's really in the
discretion of the investigation
investigating officer or the monitoring
officer and then
the committee whether they're prepared
to accept any
anything that the investigator relies on
that's set by someone anonymous it's not
ideal because obviously you want
you want to know who's what but there's
nothing prescriptive in the legislation
or in the code
that speaks about anonymity it's one of
those things that you just have to deal
with
as and when it occurs um yeah on the
issue of 4.39 i think you're probably
better
as it's mr warren's um
he's probably better answering that than
me
okay yeah sorry about that yeah if
a clumsy remark or offensive uh
i mean really it was obviously you know
i don't know how you can sort of
clung your room mark really i must have
known what he was saying
to be fair but how you came up with
a clumsy remark that was all really when
it was obviously deemed
to be offensive i would have thought
sorry councillor morley [ __ ] sorry could
i just clarify are you asking
about how we came to interview the
councillors that we did or
uh
4.39 now
page 28. um i believe this
to have been a very clumsy remark i mean
it was
the mentor it wasn't really i mean you
can't really
distinguish the two i would have thought
what's your view on that
please um
the the remark about hello sailor yes
and and it was deemed to be
a clumsy remark that that was all
to my mind it was obviously meant um
i wonder you know i mean
5.39 is councillor jarvis's own personal
view
of how he interpreted the remark
um hopefully my own thoughts in relation
to the mark
remark have been made clear in section 5
of the report
what we do is we we you know we the
first point of call in terms of the
witnesses is to try and give us an
account of what happened
and we look at all those accounts to see
if we can
reach a conclusion as to as to what did
happen
but obviously witnesses may have their
own opinions
about whether you know not only on
objectively what they saw but the the
tone manner the
uh intention um and counselor jarvis has
given us that
um but we've we've obviously set out our
own thoughts
later on um yeah
okay thank you
are you finished next one please well if
i can go back to the equalities
um station um and i can i can send this
to
uh to simon to circulate afterwards but
we do have some general
considerations around a local
authority's public sector duty
and um what um
what those duties are obviously in
relation to direct discrimination
indirect discrimination victimization
and harassment
now for remember to cause their
authority to be in breach of those laws
um it normally applies where a
member themselves acts in a
discriminatory manner
um against one of the protected
characteristics
um and as such
causes their authority to to breach
those enactments now
members may consider that um
councillor fluker um by victimizing
um cancel acetyl um
or um harassing him um
did lead the actual the entire authority
to brief the enactment
and and reach a conclusion on that um
but obviously
i've limited my considerations to those
aspects of the code
included in the report
anybody else please
yes yes councillor swain wanted to speak
cancer
thank you yes um one or two questions
for mr horum
um and it probably has a bearing on one
it's just been said
i had a little bit of difficulty with
interpreting the second sentence of 311
um that is about really qualifications
to the
validity or the relevance of the human
um
rights act um uh perhaps you can tell me
i
interpret that as meaning that and the
freedoms of expression and freedom of
speech
are limited to the extent that we have
legislation
such as that on harassment and
discrimination and so on
um perhaps uh um mr holm could confirm
whether that
have i've interpreted that correctly
absolutely councillor swain
um we have obviously legislation in
relation to discrimination and
harassment
and when members become or agree to
become councillors
then obviously the legislation in this
country
um requires them to sign up to a code of
conduct which again
um will impact on their um freedom of
speech
rights
can i call on all committee members to
vote on whether we hear
morris or not please is that seconded
out incorrect information counselor
morris will you please keep quiet can we
take a vote on where the camera points
out you take my point of order can we
take a vote please
point of order was before the vote right
yes but you're not
can you assist please is he allowed to
speak in a committee meeting when he's
not a member of this committee
uh no counsellor morris is not a member
of the standards committee
and it's only committee members that can
make a point of order
um any any other counselor that wishes
to speak
has to do so normally with prior
agreement with the
chairman a chairman obviously has
obviously has discretion
but as of right a point of order
uh statement you have to be a committee
member and and council has not put
council morris onto this committee so
you are happy
for a uh a mistake to be made even
though i'm trying to point that out
before
it continues sorry councillor morris i
have a proposal proposed by me seconded
by councillor morley
statue for cutting councillors
out of the meeting please
can i take a roll call please
take a look for you yes please
i remembers if you could just indicate
if you're for forward against
um when your name is called please uh
counselor basinger
or counselor helm
or cancer hull
that's the maze
against thank you carly council morley
councillor nunn cancer swain
four that's six four one against
chairman
that motion is julie carried can you
please cut out councils
please stop you are corrupt
for members of the public this meeting
is not corrupt
i'm afraid councillor morris keeps on
interrupting meetings and we can't get
on with the business in hand
so we now return to the business at hand
i think uh
was there any more questions from
anybody
just to conclude on that point i was
just going to say to members
that despite the legislation and
obviously despite the code of conduct it
is vitally important that members
do feel they have freedom of expression
and freedom of speech
and any decision that the code has been
breached
will automatically restrict those rights
and so it's important that members do
consider whether it's a legitimate
restriction on council of lucas
freedom of speech rights now i set out
in paragraph
3.12 um some
some uh propositions that were derived
in the uh
by mr justice hickenbottom in houston
versus the public service ombudsman
now obviously relevant to this is the
fact that
council is a politician and therefore
required to have a thick skin required
to um
put up to a certain extent with the cut
and thrust of local politics
my own view obviously i sent out in the
reasoning however is that this is a
legitimate restriction on councillor
lucas
freedom of speech rights by finding him
in breach of the code
can i then just would it be right that
you've um
reported really in relation to breaches
of the code of conduct not
in relation to any bleachers of the law
absolutely right
it seems to me that the human rights act
is engaged but
um only in limited areas um
concerning the passing of confidential
information for instance
um and this question of predetermination
of voting
um in the conservative group before
meeting
um which restricted the rights in fact
what
councillors siddhal and fleming were
doing was
exercising their right of freedom of
expression and freedom of speech
by voting as they thought fit at the
meeting rather than by some
predetermined
voting arrangement none of these matters
were relevant to my investigation this
is
i don't know if this is being dealt with
a different meeting but this is not
what's under consideration at this
meeting
okay lastly can i ask what the meaning
is in um
on page i know about the the decision
of the 30th of january meeting that it
was non-precedent
what does that mean it just means that
um
that my considerations and conclusions
are not bound by the decision members
made at that meeting
obviously members considered um two
of the uh incidents that i have
considered in my report
the hello sailor comment and the throat
cutting gesture
and whilst i haven't looked at members
considerations in great detail
i understand that they decided that the
code of conduct had not been breached
in relation to those two incidents
uh all i was pointing out is that i am
not bound by that decision
i can make my own considerations based
on the facts as i found them in my
investigation
and similarly um members here
you know should be aware that they're
today deciding whether councillor fluker
has treated councillor siddal
with um disrespectfully and whether
they've he's bullied and harassed him
over a significant period of time
um and that obviously they will to make
that decision you need evidence of
incidents where this has occurred
these are those two of those incidents
um
you're not deciding today whether
individually they represent a breach of
the code
but what you're deciding is whether a a
a
a cumulatively
uh a number of incidents have occurred
whereby
in in the round council fluke's
misconduct can be considered bullying
and harassing towards council said
thank you anybody else um
yes norman hudson can i jump in norman
yeah carry on
um sorry the the chat room it seems to
be um
um disconnected for me so i'll i'll
problem i'm afraid
all right okay um and also before i
start
let me just say um councillor is
one of my district councillors um i
had i did advise simon of this i though
i don't know
council siddal personally he is um is
obviously local to me in that respect
um i've got just a couple yes
um can i just get seek clarification
um councillor fluka obviously didn't
respond
to the investigation as i understand it
that in itself
is a breach of the malden's code of
conduct is that correct
simon
the actual i think you're referring um
you're referring
to let me just find the code itself
there is a
in our code that says that
yes you have to comply with
the let me just get the wording of it
um yes you need to comply with the
instructions
of the monitoring officer um
and and it's a breach not in relation to
any investigation
yet you must comply with any request of
the authorities monitoring officer or
section one five officer
in connection with an investigation
conducted in accordance with their
respective
statutory powers now that's wider than
just the localism act
that's any powers that they have under
the local government act as well
but i think it particularly has in mind
the localism act
now um that is a breach but
um it has to be to me a clear request of
the monitoring officer
i don't think it follows that it it in
itself is the investigating officer
although the investigating officer is
working
under the instruction of the monitoring
office so i think there would need to be
a clear
instruction from the monitoring officer
or the section 151 officer
you must cooperate with the investigator
for that to be a clear breach
in my view okay thank you
um second question uh mr orem thank you
um
there's quite a bit of reference um i
think information provided by councillor
siddal
um some of it prior to him becoming a
councillor
um some of it when within the
conservative group
um now i think in your report you you do
point that out so
it isn't taking into account in your
findings um can i ask in the
um in your investigation did
councillor settle advised that he had
made its
separate complaint to his association
about the
behavior of the councillor fluka within
the um
within the um the group meeting
i believe he did yes okay thank you
um thank you that's all my questions
thank you
right is there anybody else chairman
and councillor stilts that's the best
well councillor howell council thank you
mr auram i just
i just wonder if you could clarify that
um
in regards to the uh getting um
councillor fuku to engage with were all
the steps
taken to give him every opportunity to
engage with this investigation
he he was sent a number of emails asked
asking if he could
contact us and messages were left on his
telephone asking him to contact us
and as we've just heard i i believe that
um he would have had to respond
if he was given a direct instruction
from the monitoring officer is that
correct
um well the the um
i mean the the aspect of the code i
understand
um relates to um
being a potential breach of the code if
if he doesn't um
respond to a direct instruction from
monitoring officer but i would repeat i
i'd quickly add as well that councilor
fluker was sent a copy of the draft
report
with our provisional findings and
invited to provide any
comments he wanted to dispute any
aspects of it that he wished
and again he chose not to respond to
that
in relation to your last question
obviously members may
may consider that his non-cooperation
amounts to a breach of the code
but i would simply repeat that under the
localism act
neither the monitoring officer nor i or
anyone
has any powers to compel any party
to engage with the process and it is his
prerogative not to if he
if he wishes so could i just ask again
did you at any time instruct the
monitoring officer
to instruct counselor fluker to engage
with the interest with the investigation
uh no because i don't believe the
monitoring officer has any powers beyond
those that i have
to to get councillor um involvement or
engagement um with the process
uh the monitoring officer was though
aware that council of lucra was not
engaging with the process
but you you are you're happy that every
opportunity
was given to councillor to engage with
this investigation
absolutely um you know it did there were
there were there were efforts made to
contact him
um uh made on a numerous occasion
um and we we you know we were we were
at no time led to believe that he wasn't
aware of our efforts
to to contact
thank you very much next one please
counselor stilts chairman
all right good morning um we were saying
about article 10
of the uh humans right act well it does
say protect your right to hold your own
opinions express them freely
it then goes on to say although you have
freedom of expression
you must you also have a duty to behave
responsibility
and to respect other people's rights now
on the
mdc code of conduct um
number three rules of conduct 3.2 you
must treat
others uh with respect three points
three uphold the law
the 3.5 um
point e conduct yourself in a manner so
which could responsibly
regarded as bringing your office uh on
the authority into disrepute
so i just like to bring those ones up
because i think
uh um the code of conduct uh
does tell the wall councils of any
parish or town or district
um they've got to be reasonable and
they've got to treat other people with
respect
um and then as i say to the other one on
the humans right
they must respect other people and their
their rights
to behave responsibility and respect
other people's rights
that's my only question is this one
because earlier you were saying that
part of that doesn't cover
uh counsellors but only the action of
the council
no no the the code
um aspects of the paragraphs of the code
you refer to are exactly
the paragraphs of the code that i've
found councillor bucha to have failed to
comply with
the code of conduct absolutely isn't um
intended to restrict political debate
and it's not intended to stop
councillors being passionate and
speaking strongly
and robustly to each other about council
business
um but councillors must ensure that when
they do this
they still treat each other
respectfully and that they don't bully
and harass
each other whilst doing so and
obviously for the reasons to that in the
report i believe that council of lucas
conduct
crossed the line and that he did behave
in a manner that
failed to treat councils that would
respect and that amounted
over the course of the entire period to
bullying and harassment
right thanks for that clarification
thank you next one please anyone else
tara um yes chairman councillor hull and
then council maze wants to come back
chancellor hall please oh thank you for
letting me speak chairman
um i'm a new councillor so it's all
and i was lucky enough to be elected and
i've been um
in business thanks to molding district
council for 36 years and i
i was hoping i want to put something
back but like
some of the most of the other new
councillors we all run in businesses and
times
um quite precious to us i'm also looking
after my disabled father or he was quite
bad at the time
and when i i feel it was the end of the
meeting when this remark came
which it was not in you know context
with
i think i feel that counselor fluker was
trying to make the meeting more jovial
for us
and and trying to shorten it and because
he realized that
you know it's long meeting we have to be
at
so he shouldn't have said it but it was
a mistake
and and i hope that goes
the way also um councillor
siddal how long does he feel he's been
bullied for what was
did he give any time thank you
councillor hull uh and congratulations
on your election
um the um obviously in relation to the
first
point you made um i've set out in
paragraph 5.23
um my thoughts on on whether
um such a comment is acceptable
if it's meant jovially it's meant as
being part of um uh i don't like the
word banter but i'm gonna use it um and
i mean in the first instance uh
counselor fluker and siddill clearly
don't enjoy the type of relationship
where um people can get the mickey out
of each other
as you might have in a group of close
friends for instance
um and therefore that automatically
makes the
the behavior inappropriate um
counselor siddhel in his complaint which
is found at annex a of the report on
page 43 of the agenda pack
sets out the period of time um that he
feels
he was bullied and harassed by council
fluker
and the period in question is
effectively
from the time prior to his election
um to the the time the complaint was
made
uh there appears to have been incidents
um
on a monthly basis almost where he feels
that councillor fluka
has acted in a manner that has been
intended to
undermine him or to humiliate him or
bully or harass him
oh well i've been in most of the
meetings can you hear me okay
and yes it hadn't come across or
or nothing had been said previous to
that so
you know perhaps i'd missed out on
something but it it didn't um
it didn't come across that way i think
well obviously
yeah you know you'll have your own
you'll have your opportunity after
after this section i'm going to have to
consider whether the code of conduct has
been breached
um obviously i i asked members to
to largely focus on the content of my
report when they're making those
considerations
but obviously one of the reasons why the
localism act asks
standards committees to consider these
matters or that the council has decided
the standards committee should consider
matter is because
many of you will know those involved
many of you will have witnessed
interactions yourself um and you'll have
your own views on them
against what the type of culture you
want to see within your authority
has counts of pluto act the way that you
want your leader to act
thank you sir anybody else
uh chairman cats amazes us to come back
chancellor mayes
uh yeah thank you mr chairman no um all
points have been covered thank you very
much
okay thank you i've got a number of
points i want to raise and clarify
uh group meetings are private and
confidential so nothing in that
group meetings can be relayed to anybody
else
technically is that correct that would
be a matter for your own party counselor
helm
we have our own rules or or we did have
because i'm not in the group anymore
we did have our own rules so i feel
anything happened in group should not be
repeated outside the group and that's my
view
as for dress code as you can see jacket
thai
smart this is what councillor fluker
wants to portray in the meetings
a conservative councillor is smart and
and properly dressed so i think and and
you also mentioned
councillor fluker shouting from 20 yards
that's 60 feet that's well outside the
uh
members room which would be down the
stairs so i don't think that
can be quite relevant unless he's got
his measurements wrong
um and regard the hello sailor and all
the rest of it
he did apologize at the next meeting he
apologized to councillor siddel
by email and it seems that uh
he changed his mind after speaking to
cancer durham
councillor durham has an issue with
councillor fluker
because he was leader of the council
resigned but i can't go into the issues
because they are confidential to the
conservative party or crewsburg
group but i think i ought to set that in
motion
and let people consider that to whether
that's relevant or not
uh and i think i'll leave it at that
well i'm struggling to find the question
in their counselor
but um you know the the point i would
make
is that um an apology from a counsellor
isn't irrelevant to whether the code of
conduct has been breached or not
it may mitigate your it may mitigate
your sanction
but it seems to if an apology has been
offered then it appears that the breach
of the code has already been accepted
okay fine sorry for the uh
confusion no problem right
uh we move on now i believe
the member concerned invited to make any
representation
have we got councillor sidle here please
uh chairman i think that's a reference
to the subject member not the
complainant
yeah okay the subject member then he's
not here no okay
it's not present chairman
i believe tim we should be moving down
to um
0.7 yes the independent person invited
to make any representation or give
advice
yeah chairman yes
um may i ask a couple of questions
probably under item stages five and six
um
may i ask a couple of questions of
counselor siddall
and also a factual question of the
monitoring officer
um is that permitted simon to uh
to ask councillors from this meeting uh
that's up to you chairman
okay um i'll go ahead and my
question to the monitoring officer is
one of the fact
although i might have asked it
differently if councillor fluke had
been present and that is when do you
recall
when um councillor fluka advised
you and i think mr holmes that he had
sent
an email apology to councillor siddall
um that was
as you may be aware council swain i was
overseas for three months
um i only became aware of that apology
when um miss holmes mrs holmes the
deputy monitoring officer
had completed her report and then it was
being brought
to joint standards committee and the
issue was then raised
whether that particular apology
should be included in the bundle
that was attached to the council's
report
to them on to my report so that would
have been just before january last year
because the
the standards committee meeting dealing
with that
issue was the 30th of january my memory
serves me right
so that would probably have been a few
weeks
maybe a few weeks before bearing in mind
we've got to give five working days
notice
um of the committee meeting probably
about two weeks before that i became
aware
of the issue relating to the apology
because obviously i'd only just come
back from overseas at that point
you you can't say how soon after the
actual incident it took place then
no but that will be covered by miss
holmes report i'm sure
because she refers to it i don't
remember the details of her report but
that's in there i know there is a
reference to the apology
in the text of her report
yes right i understand um
can i ask a couple of questions of uh
councillor
siddal please uh yes if it helps
personally councillor um
israel was mr chairman
okay what's the point of order um uh
councillor siddal is not on uh is not
part of this he is a victim
um and and should not actually have to
answer questions in this
um i don't think it is covered anywhere
i'm quite happy to answer questions
i i would uh recommend that you don't
okay
i'm i'm i'm quite yeah
yeah i'm happy to answer any questions
is that all right with members
carry on then please agree yes that's
fine
thank you chairman the first question is
um is um counselor fluker in the habit
of addressing
colleagues by their surname he
he is yes um but not when
he's standing outside the leader's door
and i'm standing by the coffee machine
in the members room
with the members room door open and
it being shouted probably from about 40
foot away
at the top of his voice thank you
the second one is um in 432
you make reference i think you make
reference to the
possibility that um in the throne
incident
and you make reference to council the
fact
the factual basis for the um
uh the comment that uh you might be
trying to displace him um what is the
factual basis for that
and there is no factual basis councillor
swain
uh i just feel that part of the reason
that i became under attack from
councillor fluker
is perhaps he saw some kind of threat
in terms of my capabilities and
background
and that's perhaps where the reason why
the undermining started
right back up in selection in february
2019
thank you very much
is that it we'll go back to the
independent person please
thank you very much council siddal
[Music]
thank you councillors
no problem no problem um
i think yeah in my question i asked
about the um where the council of luger
um had a duty to respond to
the request i think that was julie
answered and i still think that
possibly um is somewhat of a
breach and certainly he's not very
polite but i can understand that
um i think there's not been a lot of
questions
asked the the report is very
comprehensive
um and it seems to me there's a lot
there's quite a bit of
information that it was
was put in the report in relation to
activities where counselor settle
wasn't a counsellor and then within the
group meeting which i think you know
counselors you have to try and ignore
that but overall it seems to me
that um there is
an element of bullying which might be it
may be
that um simply councillor fluke
and and council don't get on as
as personalities which has already been
said um
but sitting here as the independent
person as a member of the public it just
looks to me like councillor siddal
has been bullied um there was you know
not making a comment about the sort of
things like homophobic behavior or such
like because
um as i think it has already also been
said
counselors have to develop a bit of a
thick skin and that may be more
difficult
um in that situation but overall i would
just like to comment and i think i'm
going to finish there that uh
i believe councillor fluger has breached
the code
um exactly where he reached it is
probably pretty much in line with the uh
with the report so thank you
you for that any any any questions of
the
independent person um
no chairman no one's indicated all right
okay
we can move on to item eight now is that
tara
oh yes chairman that's right yeah the
committee decides if there is a breach
of the code of conduct um
do we want to do this in open session or
closed session it's up to you members
um i believe the council of nan wishes
to make a proposal
counselor none yes i i do think we
should uh
definitely conduct this in open session
chairman
and uh i've got to the stage now having
read the report extensively and listened
today to make proposition
okay what's your proposition then well i
agree with the independent person and uh
i agree with the report
and on that basis i think
whatever the intention was here
the cumulative effect
and you know we need to be clear that
it's the way that this is perceived by
a party as well as the way that it's
delivered
and i think this is a clear breach of
our code of conduct
uh particularly in relation to the lead
with the council as it was then
and i think it's very uh disappointing
that we haven't heard uh council of
lucas side of things and he hasn't been
able to respond
or he hasn't he's chosen not to respond
so my belief
mr chairman is in relation to
the covering sheets from the monitoring
officer
um that item c uh under 3.2
that's been arrived at the council of
flinker has failed
to comply with the member code of
conduct and iso
[Music]
okay
can we take a vote please could we have
a recorded vote please mr
can we have a recorder
yes right we had the training last week
and actually it was said in the training
that a post can be put forward
and second it but it must be debated by
the
by the members before voting okay then
okay
thank you very much for that norman very
much very much appreciated
um we now move on to the debate on this
who's gonna open the debate please
counselor nun would you like to start
well i i i have um uh given my
chair and i do think it's um it's a
cumulative effect
and i do think it doesn't matter whether
it was intended to be banter or not
um it's the way that it's delivered it's
the way that it's
it's the volume it's the period of time
and
it's not acceptable uh particularly from
somebody in a leadership position
and on that basis i feel that the code
has been reached
okay anybody else please may i speak
again mr chairman please yeah
councilman has indicated she wishes to
speak independent person first person
and council amazed
right thank you um right your code of
conduct
as i said earlier 3.3
councils must uphold the law now if
shouting's hello station
sailor left cancer civil feeling
harassed shaken or upset
it could be considered as a crime under
section 4a of the public order act
1984. now because the comment was made
in a public place
the public were present um
it could be reasoned that that it cause
alarm or distress to people within sight
or hearing range
this is a crime under section 5 at the
public order act
1986 so i'm afraid there's two
acts which has uh um
being um gone against
so we have to and the thing is
if this does go to court and
there's a sentence even suspended
and suspend it means if you do anything
wrong in that time then this case comes
back in again
if you are committed
even suspended for more than 90 days
i think it's the localism act or it
could be the um
represent of the people act um you'll
you immediately stop being a council of
any type of any council and that goes in
for
five years so you cannot take part in
any um election
for five years which means the next
election is 2003 i believe
because it's still within five years it
will go into the tag of the
one of 2007 which means the next
election that person can take part in is
2014 i believe
now even if you change the name there
was a case a few weeks ago
a councillor who was convicted he
changed his name and tried to stand
again
and i think he got put back in jail
again so
as far as i'm concerned crimes were
committed which is a breach of your code
of conduct number three which you must
3.3 which says you must uphold the law
thank you
okay any other members please counselor
maize was it
uh yeah thank you mr chairman um yeah i
i'm actually in agreement with
councillor stilts
um i believe that um that council of
luca has also breached
3.5 of our code of conduct little a
breach through breach of the equality
act for the homophobic remarks he made
in the chamber
as well as the public order act section
5.
furthermore i would also consider and i
think we should consider
uh 3.7 uh little
a um which says that uh is about uh his
position and i think he has
used his position as leader to convert
confer
an advantage over another member by
shutting them down
talking over them and intimidating and
bullying them and i think we really
should also consider
that breach as well as 3.2
3.5 b and 3.5
all of which have already been covered
in the report
um submitted thank you mr chairman thank
you anybody else
yes please yes councillor um
swine isn't that yes thank you
nice little that very sorry yeah i just
want to
say that i was at the council meeting in
question but
um i was not excited because of my
position in the chamber
and the suggestion that any gesture was
aimed at the
administration seems to be um
improbable since they were even worse
cited than me sitting parallel on the
other side of the chairman
um and i was at the jsc meeting on 30th
of january but only as an observer
so what i'm i mean not privy to all the
other goings on that reported on and i'm
entirely going by the the report
and i would start with looking at 5.14
um and this question about um what do we
say peripheral events
um uh which have um
been trolled by the investigator uh in
order to
establish a pattern of behavior and a
general attitude
um
but um there's a question of whether we
have to
take all of those into account i think
we have to be careful that we
concentrate on factual matters as far as
we can
and um not pay over much attention to
watch our
impressions or views of what took place
um referring back to that previous point
whether there was a breach of the law
it's not really for the
um jfc to determine that's
outside our jurisdiction but only
whether the code of conduct has been as
the expression goes
caught um 5.3
and the the references to the localism
act and this
its relevance are a little bit um
they're not very helpful because i think
we have this question of
um the actions of counselor fluker
um being either narrowly interpreted as
what happens within the
council itself in other words or between
between council of luco and
officers and and the broader question of
um how far we go in
accepting and taking into account um
actions that were outside it
um and i don't think the cases
that the that mr horan mentions really
have
too much bearing on it and they make the
contrast between
counselor actually conducting the
business of the council
in the strict sense and counsellors as
individuals i think here we're dealing
with something in between which
is admitted in a report is a other gray
area but to my
mind um what um what goes on
at the conservative group meetings is of
relevance
because the um the incidents only take
place
because council fluker
was leader and member of the council and
because the actions were taken
um the decisions at the meetings
were very much which was a prejudicial
to the council meeting itself they're
very relevant to
what happened at the meetings um
i i accepted general conclusions of the
report
that it was a consistent pattern of
behaviour
of humiliation and mocking heresy
um and there's certain meanness in the
is talk of the sexuality to officers
which comes back to
um intentions we say and also
to uh whether there's a breaches of
confidence
i don't believe um at least i find the
explanations given
and were given at the jsc meeting of
january
as believable um i'm not a yachting
person
so i don't know whether yachtsmen greet
each other by
saying hello sailor but i do know as uh
an outsider and member of the public um
how they would
um interpret it and how they would see
the um the statement
and so the actions um in the meeting
are approachable in the public eyes
intimidation over voting
and predetermination of voting which i
think
um
members of the public might find
particularly exceptional
um and rather reduces the
um the importance or significance of the
meetings themselves
and i note the lack of cooperation with
investigators
um i think that is relevant um and i'm
particularly concerned about the
incident referred to
under 429 and 430
about an officer
really not wanting to be involved and
when it was merely a question
of confirming a matter of fact to my
mind
this does have a bearing on it because
it does seem to
indicate he's sort of overbearing
influence on the council of plucker
on on officers as well as other members
so i think i can see breaches
the number of them being mentioned 3.2
3.5 b
and 3.5 e of the code but i also
agree i think what has been said about
breach of 3.4
and non-cooperation and 3.6 i think
about disclosing
confidential information um
the code of conduct includes do's as
well as don'ts
and the the seven points which are
reflections
of the localism act concerning honesty
and leadership
um and they are also incorporated in the
code of conduct
um uh have been uh contravened
themselves
we obviously have two stages now one is
to determine that
breaches have been made of the code of
conduct and before we go on i think to
the next one considering what we do
about it
thank you very much thank you
anybody else and mr quilts wishes to
come back
mr quelch please um yes chairman thanks
very much
um you already have a motion on the
table
by councillor nan seconded by councillor
mays
now in the debate quite a few other
parts of the code have been cited
and of course that's legitimate that's
all part of the debate but
um two points to make first of all is i
think counselor nurm will need to be
very clear in his proposal
what part of the code is he saying
um is breached based on his proposal and
the second point is obviously
members need to bear in mind the nature
of the complaint that was made
and the investigation into that
complaint that was made
members aren't bound by the conclusion
of the investigator but they need to
obviously
take that very much into account if you
go to page 42
of mr auram's report he himself
says that
paragraph 6.1 appendix 1
and our finding is that his conduct
counselor failed to comply with
paragraphs 3.2 which is you must treat
others with respect paragraph 3.5
b which is you must not bully any person
and paragraph 3.5 e
conduct yourself in a manner which could
reasonably regarded as bringing your
office
or the authority into disrepute now i
know that in the debate members have
mentioned
other parts of the code and of course
that that that to some extent is
legitimate but
members must be sure that they have
evidence
and you your main piece of evidence is
the investigator's report
you also need to take account of what
the independent person has said
as well in relation to the code as well
as your own
debate so members need to be very clear
that they have evidence on the balance
of probabilities
that each part of the code that they say
has been reached has indeed been
breached so
my my advice chairman to you is that
counselor nun needs to be very clear in
his proposition
which part of the code he says is
breached and
and whether that is seconded by
councillor maze i know she has already
seconded his proposition
but um i don't think code mentioned
parts of the code were mentioned
in that proposal counselor nunn would
you like to uh
thank you very much chairman and thank
you uh mr welch let me be clear then
um on the basis of what we've heard
uh i believe that the code of conduct
has been breached at 3.2
uh in relation to bullying
and answering with that within relation
to
not showing respect and in relation to
3.5
in terms of body so that's my proposed
okay that's 3.5 b
and e or just b
both okay have we got seconder for that
um i'd like to amen uh add an amendment
to
that uh proposal okay
uh chairman sorry to intervene but where
you can't um amend
a proposal the proposal is seconded or
not
correct yeah um sorry about that
can i ask councillor numb did he say
he was going to include 3.7 because i i
don't
see that that applies no is it
3.5 b and 3.5 e
is that correct councillor none yes i
mean my main contention here is that
because of the behavior
chancellor has
has been shown no respect
in terms of the code of conduct and have
been
bullied so you know whether
whether mr crouch feels i should quote
chapter reversal or not
in terms of the coding product it's 3.2
and 3.5
and 3. oh 3.5 b
and 3.5 e yes that's right
simon is that correct yeah i mean i
think i think counseling
has been very clear actually his
proposition he's he is saying
3.2 3.5 b and 3.5 v i think that's
correct
so his proposition is based on a breach
of the code of those three parts
okay which is in line with the actual
investigator's conclusion as well
i'm happy to second that okay
right so the uh the vote is on
uh councillor fluke failed to comply
with paragraph 3.2 3.5 b and 3.5
e of the council's code of conduct can
you take a
recorded vote please tara uh yes
chairman members um if when i call your
name you could just indicate
for against or abstaining please
starting with councillor bassinger
four you cancer helm
abstain thank you councillor hull
against
again against is that against cancer
molly
yes thank you very much a counselor
and counselor swain four
thank you the results of that chairman
is four four
two against and one abstention thank you
okay the so that is duly carried that
councillor fluker has broke the code of
conduct
is there any more to add to that before
i uh close the meeting or not
uh yes mr chairman oh we're going to
agree on
this yeah yes we've got to do the um
so what sanctions or what we're going to
do about this members
um chairman is it possible to make an
additional proposal
or discussion
um simon can we make an additional
proposal or not
it it depends what the proposal is i
mean uh
tell me what the proposal is the
committee has already decided that there
has been
already made a decision
on what the breach of the code is so
um there was an opportunity for that to
have been amended after been seconded
um a decision has now been made chairman
on that really the next stage is
sanctions if any
action okay right members
do you want to impose any sanctions
yes
uh yes thank you um
looking at the possible range of
sanctions some of them seem very
um um weak
and ineffective in relation to this
particular
set of breaches um and
since most of it most of the report
centers on council of lucas
approach to other people in his
attitudes
um to dealing with other people in other
words
interpersonal contact um
i want to suggest that um
he should not serve on certain of the
committees
where um dealing with um personal
conduct is concerned notably the
committees and panels on that is in 2.2
the appointments board the appointments
committee the investigating
disciplinary panel um
it seems he would not be an appropriate
person in the light of the report to
serve on those committees
simon can you qualify whether councillor
fluke has resigned from all these
committees and outside working groups
my understanding is that he has gem a
chairman
so he's already resigned from all these
outside working groups and all the rest
of it
what else would you like to do mr mr
chairman could i
come back could i speak please yes
thank you mr chairman uh yeah um if you
look at the
um sanctions um that are on page
uh three yeah yeah um
obviously i think i think what um would
be uh helpful is if if we looked at
those
to actually decide um where we go from
here
and in line with what councillor swains
just said
um i certainly would recommend to the
council full council
that the member is removed from any
official position removal from any
committee or from any working group
i certainly support that i would also
support recommending
to council that a member is issued with
a formal censure
um as um this is this is quite a serious
um situation that uh we find ourselves
in um
going forward okay
any other comments
wishes to speak yes and accounts are
still
can i take the independent person first
please
right thank you you can hear me can you
yes i can hear you all right right so
i'm not used to this one
um because of the previous
outcome of the outcome of the previous
meeting i believe
yes we should actually do the um
former and essential rep the mind which
post on the website the public need to
see
that this case has been dealt with
because previously they were left
very much unhappy with it so i think we
need to show the public for transparency
that he has been reprimanded and he's
put on the website
he's already had the training i believe
i've said in the last hearing on it so
i agree but i do very much feel that we
must put it on the website if nothing
else
counsellor none yes thank you very much
chairman
well given the clarification that we've
had from
um simon quelch earlier on
uh i believe at two on page 12
uh that we are able as a jsc
to issue um a formal censure
anyway from this committee and i would
propose that we do that
as a first point secondly i
believe that we should then refer this
to full council
for a written censure
and thirdly i
agree with councillor swain that
despite the resignations from committees
and working groups
now um that doesn't stop appointments to
committees and working groups in the
future so i think we should be doing
something
under five as far as that's concerned as
well
okay anybody else uh mr welch with you
to speak
mr clouch please thank you chairman
um in relation to the censure
there's a difference between accenture
by standards
committee and a formal censure um
i know this perhaps sounds a bit a
little bit complicated but under the
constitution
um jsc can impose their own informal
resolution on the matter once they found
a bridge and that would be
that that could include accenture as
i've as i've explained
that would be the committee themselves
saying we sent you you
and that's signed by the chairman of the
standards committee
um you can't i don't think you could
actually give a censure from standards
committee
and then recommend a formal censure by
the council
it's really one or the other because if
if the committee itself gives essentia
that that's an informal resolution of of
the matter
if the committee decides to recommend
the more serious
one or formal censure then that's
obviously a decision of
counsel um you can't do both
in relation to um my advice in relation
to committee meetings
is that councillor fluke as i understand
it
is still on the district planning
committee
and he is still on the area planning
committee
now members can recommend removal from
that to council if they wish
obviously they can't remove councillor
fluke from council because he's been
elected by the people he's a cancer so
you can't remove from that
all other as i understand it
appointments
uh personal working groups and
committees he has resigned
from now i don't think it's for
i don't believe in that recommendation
members have the power
to recommend to council that for the
future
um uh uh council of lucas should not sit
that would then be a decision for
council
itself at the next annual meeting who to
put on
which committees and council will know
therefore of the decision of this
committee that there has already been a
finding
of a breach of the code if you see what
i mean
yes
right members yes
i find i find that advice straight
because uh i don't think there's
anything wrong with joint standards
committee
writing to council fluker to inform him
of our displeasure uh in relation to the
outcome
and telling him that we are recommending
a
formal sanction to full
council so we could do that
and secondly um even in employment
circles a warning has a life
and if we're saying under recommendation
five about removal from committees and
working
groups um that we don't that doesn't
apply because he's not on any
um what's to stop at the annual meeting
which is not that long
off councillor fluke are being appointed
to those groups of working
uh those working groups and communities
i would say
um for the for the period of 12 months
okay that can be seconded i would agree
with that
okay
yeah just just i i think i probably
misunderstood counsellor nunn
if if councillor nunn's um uh proposing
that there is the councillor luca is
informed
that jsc is recommending formal censure
then i agree
that is legitimate i have misunderstood
council and i thought he was proposing
that there was essentia
from jsc and also a recommendation of a
formal censure
to council but as i understand it he
simply if i've understood correctly he
is actually only suggesting
or proposing uh informing
counsellor fluker of the recommendation
for a formal sentence in which case that
that's quite legitimate
okay i am chairman uh but in so doing
we've informed him that we are
um by majority um believe that he has
breached the code
is that all right simon is that a
proposal do we have
yes that that is acceptable and i'm
sorry i misunderstood uh
counsellor known that that that is
acceptable
okay so uh council done with your
proposal was
so my proposal then chairman is that
with a carefully worded letter
produced in association with the
monetary officer and the independent
person
we write to councillor to tell him
the outcome of today's hearing
and regret that he wasn't present
and that he didn't cooperate with the
investigation but that the committee by
majority
has bound uh against him and will be
recommending to full council
a formal censure uh in addition
this committee will be recommending that
he is not committed to serve on
committees and working groups
for the next 12 months i'll second that
does that include the two planning
committees he's still on or not
yes okay yes okay all right
someone wanted to say something
nobody oh yes chairman
um i i particularly mentioned
the the groups that he was um
involving um dealing with people should
we say um i'm a bit hesitant about
um through depriving
is the south minister of half of their
representation
on the council for other policy matters
um because this is essentially about
personal personal attitudes and so on
rather than
um efficiency or proficiency
in conducting um council affairs
he should have thought about that though
councillor swain before he made these
actions
my second did proposal stands chairman
okay tara can we take the vote please
do you want the recorded vote
yes please yes
[Music]
uh yes chairman uh members um if you can
again um just
indicate if you're four against or
abstaining when i call your name please
uh say uh council messenger
thank you council helm stein
i i lost my internet so okay
thank you very much
the swing four the results of that
chairman is
five four and one abstention thank you
very much
thank you very much everybody is there
any other things we have to discuss tara
hey no chairman there are no other items
of business
as far as i'm aware of them okay i have
no other items in business at this
moment
and i duly close the meeting thank you
very much members
thank you thank you thank you mr
chairman you put up with me all right
because
thrust on me straight away i didn't know
what i was doing for a start no
preparation